okay
okay you know live okay thanks very much
dom
okay welcome everybody to uh ons
internal uh and especially to those who
go and watch us on youtube
um we will go straight into
um our agenda
because um all the all you members know
about declarations of interest and all
this sort of thing and we're on zoom and
v8
okay right okay murray
are you there yes chair apologies for
for absence then chair we have apologies
from councillor bowton i don't think
he's found a sub
and we have apologies from councillor
newton councillor hurley is subbing
lovely thank you we're going to the
minutes of
um the last two meetings
and i'd like to just make it uh
that we only uh get married to do this
once
so we have a meeting on the 10th of
november
and the only person that um wasn't there
is tony so you'll have to abstain for
that tony
yes mr chairman and and
the meeting on the 29th of september
everybody was present so yeah
yes sorry apologies have we not already
approved the 29th of september minutes
on the meeting of the 10th of november
okay i suspect the 10th of november
meeting was a special meeting was it
yeah did you deal with the calling so
you may not have had minutes at that
meeting
okay no
no we did the 15th of september
and on the other side of that sorry
okay i i thought we had to prove them
sorry sure
okay it's okay forget i'll forgive you
so
mary can we go into the vote and tony
you make sure you abstain for the 10th
of november
and david you will have to abstain on
both anyway okay
i know yeah okay councillor cottle
hankin
mr harper paul
councillor hurley abstain thank you
councillor inch uh abstain
councillor langford oh mary
could i just stop you there yeah tony
you abstain for the 10th of november
but not for the septem 29th of september
oh sorry chair right okay uh alter that
for abstain and and
okay yes okay okay
counselor manly
thank you councillor watson
thank you thank you
okay thanks thanks mary
we go on to the action list which is on
19 and 20.
uh minute 69 that's still ongoing
so we'll keep that on
uh mini 8th 7th of july
for the qbr four 19 to 20 electric car
charging we'll keep that that's ongoing
right minute 43
uh 10th of november that was completed
sent as part of the minutes
so we can remove that
um mini 43 10th november another one
waste review to include all members of
in the consultation that was completed
email sent and response received
so we can remove that minute fortified
forward plan
um capital program december that's
completed so
that's that's done we'll go now on to
public contributions where i don't
believe we've got any tom
that's john yeah that's correct yeah
right okay
declarations of interest you all you all
understand
about the decorations of interest so i
won't have to go through
that uh then item six
urgent matters brought forward with the
permission of the chair well
i've got something to bring forward that
item nine i'm going to defer
item 9 to our february meeting
uh for a more in-depth report it is
it's the capital programme and we've got
steve stevens there uh stephen
was just going to explain to you why yes
uh thanks chair um so the the original
uh process was for members of the
internal scrutiny to scrutinize
the draft capital program that was
presented to community resources
on the 7th of december last week
it transpired from that that meeting
that more information
is required within the capital program
around some of the projects
and some of the funding so we're
proposing to bring
the capital program back to community
resources committee
at their next meeting and therefore
um your committee your internal organ
scrutiny committee will be able to
scrutinize that
at your february meeting along with the
the rest of the budget
before it goes on to full council for uh
final approval okay that's essentially
it
right thanks steve okay
right we'll move on to item number eight
uh and i believe this is where's sarah
there she is
oh sorry sorry
i'm just trying to get on for him yeah
um
agreement of agenda parts one and two
well we've got no part two
so now we go on to item number eight
and welcome sarah to give us a little
update
and i i think she needs to know a bit
more information about what she's got to
do
is that right okay thank you chair yeah
i'll i'll run through some
key information that i've got to date um
so i was asked to look at the impact of
covid in relation to working from home
and zoom meetings
and the potential savings that has been
made together with
work-life balance so as you'll be aware
we've been working continuously to
implement arrangements to deal with the
ongoing response to covid
and that has included more flexible
working arrangements for staff
home working has been a key feature of
that and
i would say that most staff have worked
some of their time from home
apart from of course our waste and
recycling
staff so some key information so in
relation to
um councillors and financial savings
so overall there's been a reduction of
88
in the budget so by far the biggest
saving
has been from car mileage
which has seen quite a big reduction
because obviously
councillors are attending virtual
meetings rather than
attending at the town hall and other
smaller savings for councillors include
things like catering car parking
persistence and training
so there have been an additional cost
for zoom licenses
so we've purchased licenses up until
march
21 and that cost has been just
under 4 000 pounds we have
23 hosts that can arrange meetings
and 83 registered in zoom
with their tdc email address
all users so 200 staff and all
councillors also
have access to teams
between march and october this year
there's been a total of 809
virtual meetings with almost 5 000
participants across the council
so in relation to staff so
prior to the lockdowns at the beginning
of the year we had on average
two to three percent of staff working
from home
from the announcement in the on the 23rd
of march we pretty much overnight
increase that to 80 percent
so again that's the majority of staff
apart from those for example in wasting
recycling that obviously can't
do their jobs from home so we made
various equipment available to staff
which included
63 laptops 99 monitors
16 phones etc so everybody
was allocated equipment to be able to
work effectively from home
in relation to the uh home working so we
do a staff survey
each year and this year we asked
specific questions about homeworking and
how
staff had found that and
their their further analysis needs to
take place but initial indications show
that whilst it's worked well there are
some
concerns and these are primarily
related to feeling socially isolated
more difficult to perhaps communicate or
work closely with their teams
and some stuff particularly not having a
dedicated home working space
so we have the results of the staff
survey um
are with us now so i just need to go
through them and analyze them a little
bit closer
um closely and obviously can report back
any further analysis of that of the kind
of benefits of working from home and
perhaps
some of the issues that staff have faced
all right so that's a very kind of quick
overview
of um what's happened since we've had
the changes in
in home working and virtual meetings and
obviously i can
i can report back on further information
from a staffing point of view when once
i've looked at the survey results
okay that's great sarah anybody got any
questions for sarah
oh sorry it's me
cancer inch raised hand
sorry i hadn't switched on the
participant
thank you terry thank you sarah for that
report that's very good
um i wonder if uh
if we had any uh concerns over mental
health over the
period with our staff as you say working
in isolation also
um not being able to uh communicate with
their
peers um problem solving perhaps
where you would have in an office
environment where you can ask your
uh perhaps junior members could ask your
senior members
advice and things like on things like
that
and also the other thing is as well
i know you've done a survey with staff
but perhaps we should do a survey with
members as well
because um i think we've all been
um being shut away as it were
and uh and i'm just wondering if if
staff
have had any sort of like feelings or
um over over the zoo meetings and if
it's been
beneficial to members or not beneficial
to them i mean
perhaps we should just do a survey with
members as well
that's all chair okay lovely
david airlie where are you i'm here
chair thank you very much
yeah just a quick question through the
chair sarah how many meetings did you
say
zoom meetings have there been between
march and october 109.
okay thank you thanks
109 sarah
hundred and nine eight hundred and nine
i thought you said a hundred and nine
okay
it's all that hair and and
as opposed to cover
tony did you want to come back
just another thing chair is as well of
course and
with all this i don't know if sarah can
answer this but i mean it must have made
a big difference on our carbon footprint
as well
i mean we've signed up to the carbon to
the uh
climate change you know carbon neutral
by 2030
and perhaps we should take that into
consideration as well when we
decide whether or no perhaps
if we have more zoom meetings in the
future even when we come out of this
covet thank you chair yeah
i must admit hey would you like
i can just come back on the um couple of
points
with regards to mental health um
yeah that that has been a concern to us
so we have issued guidance
to managers on how to deal with that
and some advice about keeping in touch
and providing support to staff
we also have an occupational health
service that we can refer
people to because of course it's not
just for homeworking but
it's affected everybody in their
day-to-day lives as well so we've we've
made use of that
um back as well and it there's a whole
range so yes we have staff that
thoroughly enjoy working from home and
the flexibility it brings and
others that are very very keen to return
but what we have tried to do is to get
most staff back in at least some of the
time on a rota basis so they do have
that
contact with their colleagues and their
peers and
they still have that opportunity to
discuss issues
um in relation to the the travel i
haven't got
any specific information about that but
clearly
there's been significant savings all our
training this year has been
virtually so where staff may normally
attend
i don't know professional development
course in extra bristol
of course all that's been um been
undertaken
virtually so there will be significant
savings there
and of course for things like uh fight
visits and
normal day-to-day work because a lot of
employees jobs have changed so for a
while
planning officers weren't doing site
visits building control
weren't out visiting so um yes we
we can get together some information
about travel savings
okay that's great that's great
okay uh phil philip pennington you're
next
sorry you sarah thank you um just to
clarify the figures 809
meetings and a total of 5 000
participants
averages only six a meeting
surely when you have a meeting like a
full council you've got 50 participants
there
so there must be some meetings you only
have in two is
is that
have i got the figures right
misunderstood the figures
809 meetings and 5 000 participants
oh yes
they were the figures that i gave you
actually i'd need to check
okay and just the averages when you see
the other big meeting like full council
last night
i think there was more than 50 people
counselors and officers there all
together
so if you average that out i mean that
that's more than six meetings
effectively and
i just didn't tie up sarah because it
goes from there
and secondly just on that we've had to
get new internet
connections in because of the culvert
because we had very poor broadband peter
watson helped me an awful lot on that
also thank you peter
um but we've got a really good download
speech has there been any exclusion
in the rural areas have people not been
able to get on
it's noticeable sometimes it's always
the same counselors when we come to the
vote
they're taking a long time to respond
and i just wondered whether that is due
to poor
broadband connections i don't know if
you've done any research around that
thank you chair okay phil
you want me to come back on that one
sarah
and now i haven't done any research
about the internet connections but i can
certainly discuss that with it
and and come back with some information
on that thank you
from chair i can i can give a little bit
of an update if you like
yeah okay john when we first um
implemented this uh tom and i kind of
dealt with a lot of the
the councillors and everything um there
was a
a little bit of issue of um
some councillors having um problems with
broadband speeds
funnily enough councillor pennington was
one of the
worst even though he was so close to
biddeford um
mainly the rural ones that do do very
well
and we haven't had anyone with um really
major problems
um and we were quite surprised at that
um
the the stability um of the broadband
speeds and the connections have been a
lot better than we anticipated to start
with
we've had a couple little wobbles um in
a few meetings
some of that was down to really bad
weather
we had initial problems with
thunderstorms
but overall um the the connectivity and
and the the way we managed it um has
worked really well
thank you john thank you chair yeah i i
i noticed that
anna seems to have a problem
but i would have thought she'd have got
good internet in in auckland
but she seems to have a problem i mean
she kind of had a bit of a problem last
night
but anyway anyway so would you say once
it's always the same ones
yeah yeah just coming back um councillor
penton's question
regarding the number of people on zoom
means i'll double check that number and
confirm it to him later down in front of
me
but just to say that staff have been
using
zoom for especially at the start for a
lot of one-on-ones with
team members and managers so the numbers
probably are correct because it's only
council meetings that have high
quantities of people in the actual
committee meetings
thank you thank peter ames
yeah it's um in terms of using zoom
instead of physical meetings
i mean one suspects that um
well i don't know i was just going to
say that there is a carbon cost
to going on there is a carbon cost going
on
zoom um in terms of going on to the
internet
be interesting to have some figures
about what the carbon cost of that
is but i suspect it's probably better
than
actual actually driving to physical
meetings but
then of course as as has been said there
are sort of downsides of um
going on zoom and being isolated all the
time but uh
it will be interesting to get get
figures about the carbon cost
okay john walter
you want to come back john yes chad just
just to give an update on
kind of the rural um
meetings at the moment now the
government legislation currently
um allows us to hold these remote
meetings is only in place until may
so the government for us to continue
that the government will have to
make the legislation um or either extend
it or change it
um to allow us to hold meetings remotely
now we do know that the lga
are lobbying for this to be done because
there seems to be a lot of
[Music]
councils and councillors seeing the
benefit of these remote meetings
[Music]
there are also talks going on about
whether any of them can be
hybrid meetings where you could can do
both
um tom attended a seminar on that quite
recently to
to learn from brett's practice um and
interestingly there wasn't a lot of best
practice because it's new to
to most councils in the country um
but but there is a lot of um information
and discussions going on behind the
scenes
to see whether or not this can continue
and
and how um and what the government feel
of this
so it's kind of what's the space for
that okay
okay let's have a look shirley where are
you
thank you i just wondered how difficult
has it been to
induct new staff and give them the
support they need
when you've um not been able to be in
the office much at all i can't
imagine it must have been really tricky
both making appointments
and then settling people in
i'm mute sarah unmute
that's it yeah um yes we have had a
number of new starters
um and it yeah it's been a little bit
difficult but what we've tended to do is
get them into the office
initially so they can actually meet some
people and have an induction
face-to-face
and then they've gone home working like
the rest of the staff and then returned
to the office on the rota basis
so i think it's worked okay so far
recruitment wise we've held some
interviews virtually and we've held some
face to face
so we have rooms uh where there's
there's enough space actually to be
socially distanced and obviously
our preference really is before we make
an appointment to
to meet people um face-to-face to have a
discussion
so certainly for the higher level posts
we've done that
all right thank you donate
yeah thank you chair um i was just
thinking about
members again um whether or not we can
have uh
perhaps junk in a range or somebody like
that can arrange a
uh a survey for members to see how
they've got on
through the covert 19 and to see
exactly the same as how staff the staff
survey is really
um because you know we've all had to go
through this uh
kovit 19 uh it'll be just
it'll be just um interesting to see how
members feel
about uh zoo meetings in the future
um and and how they've coped with it so
far
thank you chair okay thanks tony
david yeah come back on that yeah that
was something that sarah and i have
discussed
doing um already and i think the purpose
of this
uh update today was just to get and
gather some thoughts from
members of the committee other things
that could go into the report so
that's something here and i had already
discussed and thought would be
a useful addition yeah thanks steve
david ellie language chair i think
there's a place
um for zoom particularly when it comes
to maybe
a cancer having a couple pieces to go to
in an evening or whatever you can make
he or she can make both whereas before
it might be very difficult
but i don't think you can beat
face-to-face meetings
for the social contact if nothing else
um
often we've seen we have had problems
with broadband occasionally
but it does allow a lot more people to
participate in the meetings who may not
have done so but yeah i think there's a
place for both but i'm looking forward
to getting back to
proper face-to-face meetings thank you
chair lovely
okay right then i don't think there's
anybody else wants to
ask sarah question so we'll
move on from that and thanks for that
sarah did you did well
and and i think you've got enough
information now that we
what we need to have for you to bring
back yeah
or maybe we could just do it yeah or we
could just put it out online
whichever you want it's up to you sarah
okay
obviously you like to come and speak to
us so obviously
you're very welcome you're very welcome
to come
thank you okay right guys we'll move on
uh we've skipped number nine we're on
number 10 treasury investment options
and we have got with david
i'm here i'm here chair oh yeah
okay um treasure investment
options 31 to 33
okay so this is quite a short report
this is a report back from a task and
finish group
looking at the council undertaking
ethical investment
or otherwise known as green treasury
deposits yeah
uh the council currently has a treasury
management policy
which has three criteria and in order
they are security security of our
deposit the liquidity how quickly we can
access the money
and our yield and the working party
looked at um
how we might undertake ethical um
investments and green
investments and essentially they came to
the conclusion that we would like the
council
to where possible to undertake
short-term treasury deposits
in an ethical and green manner and the
criteria we set was that
the institutions we deposited our money
would have to be uk registered
they would have to have a fixed one
rating and that the interest rate would
be
within point two of a percent of
standard treasury deposits
as we speak today there is actually no
difference in the interest rate
either deposit returns so it wouldn't
cost the council anything if we went
down the
ethical or green investment route in for
short-term treasury deposits compared
with standard
treasury deposits and the recommendation
is simply that we
recommend as a group to full council the
council changes its um
treasury management policy to be that
the default position
is that the council invests short-term
depositing green
treasury deposits where it meets the
acceptable criteria i.e it's a uk
registered bank it has a fixed one
rating and the rate is within point two
percent
of a standard treasury deposit so it's
quite a simple report really
okay thanks david right
questions okay peter
ames
yup yup thanks jim um yeah i mean this
is
this is uh part of the climate emergency
commitment
um it's um a situation where if we
invest in green investments
current um we we fit the criteria set
down
as david has outlined so
i would hope and strongly urge this
committee to
approve the recommendation but i'm not
totally happy with the recommendation
because as i
recall at the working group we agreed to
prioritize green investments
and the recommendation is to include
green treasury deposits in the
investment
portfolio um i know dave
and david said it's the default position
to prioritize but it doesn't actually
say that in the recommendation
and i would propose that we add the
words uh
to include and prioritize investment
in green treasury deposits
i'm happy then david would you like to
come back
on that yeah no that's fine i think
that's probably council james is correct
we should actually change it to
prioritize um green treasury deposits
where they meet the
the following criteria and then we list
what the criteria are on page 32
which is uk registered banks
um and the interest rate is within point
two percent of treasury deposit
standard treasury deposit rates so it
should be prioritized
where it meets the following criterion
the criteria would be uk registered
fitch one rated bank
and within point two percent of the
standard treasury deposit rate
is that accessible to you council hayes
yeah i think that
makes yeah yeah okay
okay david early thank you chair
if we go down this route the green
treasury deposit
will that not restrict us and what we
can invest in in future what
a bank may invest in um who was on the
income
generation working group please um
and we're talking about ethical
investments we're just going to ethical
investments is that
all we will do will not invest elsewhere
thank you chair david
i suppose the answer to that is we would
go down this route so long between point
two percent
of another rate we could get so if we
could get a rate that's better than
point two percent of the green
investments
we would go down the most economically
advantageous deposit
um at the moment they are just like
basically comparable
there is actually literally no
difference between them um
and also to a large degree depends if
i'm honest on how long we can put the
money aside for
at the moment we're very in a short-term
window
okay so in some respects we're not
losing out on anything we're losing out
just to give you as
that equates the point two percent of a
standard treasury deposit which i've
alluded to exactly is the same at the
moment is two thousand pounds per one
million pound investment
so it's you know it's off somewhat on
the margins um council hurler
and if if there's a great diversion
between the rates
we would seek the better return
okay thank you deb through the chair we
if i can respond to that
um we've looked at this in the past and
the ethical investments
gave it a lower return than where we
were
already i believe i'm right in saying
that so we haven't taken that route
now would there be a problem what you've
just said that probably wouldn't be
removing our money from an ethical
investment bank or
what you call a green treasury deposit
and putting into a higher
rate higher paying deposit would there
be a problem because i suspect there
would be
if we've gone to the green um treasury
side
i suspect those who possibly on the
income generation working group
wouldn't be very happy if we changed
from that in view of the uh climate
uh change um route we're taking and who
who was on the working group please do
we know do you know
i'm gonna answer that chair and i'll
come back on the um yeah there was
myself
peter ames um
oh dear somebody help me yeah i can't
remember now
councillor christie oh yeah peter
christie he was on it
um i'm steve then gate
and that was it that was it
okay just a thought because if everybody
on the group
was all for green a green form
investment then
you don't have a ballast opinion well
and i'm not saying people are that way
it's just
that's just the way i would see it i
said so i mean i i
i look at it in this way we want to do
this
but for me if
if by going doing green investments
it wasn't really working out and we were
losing
uh a lot of money then i don't believe i
believe we should revert back well we're
not giving up
the old ways anyway david are we
it's worth me just adding something for
cancer at least benefited
yeah go on um counselor early um
at the end of the day this policy would
need to be an update to the treasury
management policy
which would need to be reviewed and
approved at full council
anyway so other members viewers who
may not be green-minded
as green-minded as another member would
have the opportunity
to voice their opinion at that point and
then obviously it'll be up to the 36
members to
approve this inclusion or not
okay thank you i'd just like to say
through the chair though if a
recommendation comes from this committee
that may sway some minds who may not
have felt going
that was right to go that way in the
first place i mean when i see a
recommendation from a committee i look
at it the committee's gone through this
and they've taken the best route so that
sometimes helps me make my mind up that
was all
this is only this is only to include
green treasury deposits
prioritized well prioritize
yeah that's fine peter but you know
there's no way that i'm going to sit
here
or or in any other meeting and and let
this council
be totally out of pocket just because of
greek
just because of green um treasury
deposits
i can't do that you know i mean it's
fine i mean as
as david has said at the minute it's
it's on a par
we'd probably lose two thousand pounder
per million
that's fine but if if things went wrong
in the wrong way
then we have to look after the council
first
and then and we're looking at green
green green
all the time which yeah we're fine
i mean let's not forget one thing devon
county council leading on
on the green on the green part of it and
and so
yeah i i will look at it later but
at the moment green seems pretty good
um yeah i mean it's should be very
pretty
clear in the resolution isn't it in
terms of losing money etc
and whether we have the freedom to go to
other investments but i think that
the nub of it all is that if there's any
change then it should be fully monitored
by full council or cnr or whoever it is
yeah i mean if it's been proposed that
we we revert to investing in
for instance in fossil fuels i would
hope very much
that this council that our council would
have the chance to
have their say and monitor it because
well i'm sure
i'm sure i'm sure this council would do
as it doesn't tie in with our climate
objectives if we go back to fossil fuel
investment in my view nobody's
mentioning about
fossil fuels but but there are other
investments that
probably aren't green but you know
anyway
right chair can i just respond just as a
working group
um just for councilman hurley you're
right we did look at this before
um some of the products that were
available to us on this review
weren't available to us at the previous
review so the actual
gap in loss as it were or difference
in investment was smaller or
insignificant
whereas previously you're right it was a
much wider
a much more added margin yeah
okay thank you thank you very much i
just didn't want us to get carried away
on a
a wave of green if you like that don't
worry david
we won't get caught thanks chad on a
wave of greed
peter chris is coming on next he's going
to get carried away
can i just say that uh this idea of
investing in ethical investments
councillors will know i've been banging
on about this for years
and having declared a climate emergency
it would seem
a bit silly not to go down this avenue
and ring
would ring very hollow with the voters
um if i just give some comfort to
councillor hurley
um i'm the chairman of the british trust
in biddeford i'm the chairman of also
the north devon athenian
over imbancable and we have both
organizations we have investments
seven-figure sums and
both organizations we've put all our
money into ethical investments
now up until uh earlier this year
in back in march they weren't the best
performing
they were the second best the best were
property ones
and of course we've all seen what's
happened to property investments
uh shopping malls that we've all you
know we know about the councils that are
going bankrupt from putting all their
money in them
and ethical investments are actually
the best in the long run because we even
today
we get uh the government talking about
more renewables and so on
and this is the way we've got to go and
as a council i think we need to do this
um but if it gives counter hurley any
comfort they are
actually very good performing
investments
okay fine i'm quite pumped check and i
come back yes you can come back to that
very briefly i'm quite happy
with that uh peter um i've got no
problem with that what i didn't want is
to have a situation whereby
uh green if you like is all powerful and
we go for that
whether you like that green's all
powerful without looking
at what we could obtain elsewhere and i
take your point about shopping miles
they have changed dramatically
uh as an investment partner as a result
of covert
and i think that it will probably still
be going down in value
whereas ethical investments could well
be going we're going up that obviously
seems to be the way to go
so i'm quite happy to go over that
provided we are looking as a council
that we're not losing money by sticking
with the same investments which are fine
today but it may not be fine tomorrow
thank you i totally agree with that
david yes who was that
okay i was just going to come back
quickly if that's okay i guess what we
what we need to do what you need to do
is
um david reports
items on investment capital program etc
through the courtney business report um
it could include
an item that identifies
the kind of notional cost if you like of
investing in these types of funds
as opposed to the rate that could have
been achieved
in investing in other funds their
members will see the cost
of investing in these type of funds and
if members then feel
it's something they no longer wish to do
because of the cost
uh then the treasury management policy
can be updated at a later stage
should members wish to to do that
so we can be monitored if we monitor the
the business business report
the members can then take a view as to
what to do in the future
not forgetting not forgetting the cost
to the environment
okay you understand that david
are you happy yes yes i do understand
obviously we
this will have to be formally approved
by full council so
it's unlikely to be any quarterly
monitoring that'll be undertaken in the
current financial year
right that's fine dude anyway we we have
the recommendation to center for council
mary could you read it out again please
because it's changed a bit to what's on
the sheet
hello mary sorry chad
just bear with me i'm flicking back
okay so um it's to include and
prioritize
no greenh
[Music]
members recommend full council update
the treasury management policy
to prioritize green and treasury
deposits and they're
subject to the dave
you unmute david okay so shall i start
should we start again
yeah okay apologies members recommend to
full council to update the treasury
management policy to
prioritize green treasury deposits where
the following criteria
are met yeah the the monies are
deposited uk
registered banks are building societies
that have a fish f1 rating
and that the interest rate is within 0.2
percent of standard treasury deposit
rates
right okay
every everybody got that can we
can i have a proposal that we send this
recommendation to full council
yeah peter ames i'll second it okay
um mary can we i think we need to have a
vote yep
councillor cottle hankin or
mr dengate oh
or mr harper
or councillor hurley
or council wrench
sorry yes four councillor langford
four councillor manly
oh council watson four
thank you okay thanks very much for that
right
uh we on item number 11
review of the qbo to set up a task and
finish group
um okay we'll go with
chair vice chair who who else would like
to be on the task and finish group
blimey everybody's oh chair would you
like me just to explain
the purpose of the test yeah yeah like
you can explain the purpose yeah
yeah so so members have um approved
their new
um strategic plan so what we want to do
now is to look at the
qbr and align the actions and the
measures and everything like that to the
new strategic plan
it's also probably time we did that it's
been a few years since we
we had a look at the qbr so we'd like to
sit down with members
um probably over zoom in
in early uh january yeah to sit down
and agree um what they want
reported on the qbr going forward
so there'll be a couple of meetings
probably to
to to go through it and and agree what
um
what we're going to report going forward
okay fine
chair i'd be happy if there's no one
else wanting to
is that you stephen yeah right okay
peter aim do you want to be on it yeah
he said be a couple of meetings do you
chen
did you yeah john yeah thank you chair
so this myself
peter ames stephen dengate who else
wants to be on it
could we nominate councillor newton
sorry could we nominate councillor
newton in his in
in his absence yeah you can have
councillor newton and
shirley do you want to come yeah i've
not done one of these before but i'd be
quite interested
okay yeah well yeah yeah you ought to
you have to come
and do it and try it thanks all right so
we've got that mary who's going to be on
that
task and finish
yeah so yes chad you you're right mary
yeah did you want it right back or not
no okay
we know who's going to be on the task
and finish that's fine
uh we're going to item 12 now
consideration of the forward plan so
let's look at the forward plan
well
obviously today's the we've took the
capital program off
today but on the 9th of february
we have the budget special and
included uh additional to that is it
going to be the capital program
which we'll be looking at in more in
depth so
i'm sorry you've had it you've had an
easy easy meeting today
but please make sure on the 9th of
february
you're here for a long time i mean i
i can go back and tell you when when i
used to do it with
ons internal when phil collins was chair
it was an all-day meeting
not not just a couple of hours not two
or three hours
it was all day we used to go through the
pids
one by one everything but you know so
this won't be too bad it won't be too
bad just prepare yourselves all right
don't mind if you want to break and have
a drink or god knows what else just
but we need to discuss it really need
the capital program we
really need to look at it because there
are things on there that
i don't think we'll ever be able to do
with the amount of money that
we haven't got so we'll have a good
we'll have a good um
work at it okay pete what time someone
start
sorry 10 o'clock mary where is it
oh joe yeah it's
budget special meetings it's 10 o'clock
i'll just open my new diary
okay i'll change my day of work
right but it's going to be a long one i
can't believe it
it will it will be a long meeting
yeah not not all day but
i would say it's going to be a long
meeting i think you can probably
book yourself in for three or four hours
okay yep
well you never told us this but anyway
so yeah i mean then 23rd of march
we've got the qbr3
and that's where we'll have we'll do an
update from the task and finish group
for the qbr and
then in may we've got the climate change
carbon plan
um anybody sorry
jeff yeah i said we hope we have the
carbon plan
well yeah well i'm sure we're well chair
sorry yeah can i just yeah yeah can i
just give a quick update on that
yes you can john we've put it there for
may um just as a reminder but
jan williams has said that she hopes to
have it earlier
and if you recall chair that you agreed
that if necessary
we may hold a special meeting just to
discuss that yes
that's fine yeah we did john yeah i
forgot about that i'm glad you're here
john
yeah okay yeah hoping for january i
think
okay just a couple are we are we open
for january i think that's what you told
me last time yeah
um all right okay jer can i just i just
wondering about
can we put yeah we talking about for
future review
whether i'm just wondering about
conservation areas and listed buildings
whether
we could have a look at that and in
terms the resources available
for uh enforcing regarding
listed and buildings and stuff and
the resources available to do spot
listings etc in the council
and also um a review of
um the listings because as i understand
it hasn't been done
since about 2003 um i'd be interested
to to hear what steve had to say about
that
or sean maybe if he's here
sean's not a chair sean's not on the
meeting today because there's nothing on
the agenda
for him sorry steve
obviously you've got quite a full
schedule for your next couple of
meetings so it might be something
in preparation for your next year's plan
yeah um because i was gonna refer
something
to the forward plan that need would
probably also need
to be looked at in terms of the grounds
maintenance contracts oh
yeah and the review of that during this
year to
ascertain what members might wish to to
recommend
for future years so you've got quite a
few things on the
next couple of meetings already and
obviously
you've just resolved that the homework
and zoom meetings
um giving sarah a bit more uh
information requirements to
uh complete that report so that would
need to go on to one of these two
meetings as well so
um you know we've got a full agenda for
the rest of this year so
if councillor haims his suggestion i
guess it needs to be
um put in a bit more detail and first we
understand
exactly what the committee wants to look
at
because obviously we've had the same
with the zoom meetings and the homework
and
what we'd want to do is come back and
ask for more information
it's better if the details are agreed
up front hmm do i be into next year i
was thinking
not immediately yeah the other thing was
i mentioned last night about the schla
process but
um but we wrote at northern about three
years ago
to torridge saying about
that more public access to the process
quoting government guidance which i've
just checked again today
um which advises that there should be
full local participation
um i don't know where that summit cut
will come up under the local plan review
or
whether it's something i'm sure that
will come under the local plan review
yeah okay yeah okay
okay um okay
tony you're you're on what oh yes thank
you chad i was just going to remind you
and
uh others as well that the fourth of may
is two days before the devon county
county elections so um i'm just um
flagging it up that some of us might be
rather busy
on right on that day anyway
not uh not that i'm saying i'm standing
or anything else but you never know
you never know you're looking a raffle
mate
[Laughter]
just just to say chair that that may be
yeah um
a bit too much for for some people yeah
well
we we can we can look into that when it
gets nearer the time
yes yes sir thank you okay uh
in ian ian
just opera you chair a couple of things
um
with the capital programme is it
possible to understand what the pids are
and how they're actually assessed
for instance um what are the criteria
um what is the scoring and really what
is the weighting of them
okay chain response what we're proposing
to do or still come to
cnr and your scrutiny committee is hold
as we would normally do an informal
event
in advance of the committee meetings to
go through some of that level of
detailed members
um rather than go through each
individual page
um in detail because many of them have
been in the capital program
and approved and approved for a number
of years so we'd
intend holding a pre um workshop with
members just to go through some of the
finer detail
okay well a zoom meeting um something
like that
david's just yeah um we're looking at
maybe the 13th and 14th of january
early next year yeah myself tom
and my colleague peter hudson are going
to sort of try see how we can make
the event interactive using polls for
example
so we're going to have to sort of work
through the kind of so it's trying to
replicate what would be an event up at
cadstown
um so it'll be a presentation then it'll
be members may be polled on certain
decisions
we'll put through the decisions that the
members have made and see how that
influences the funding gap that we have
and we'll try to do that in an
interactive manner as
but that's an aspiration at the moment
we haven't actually delivered that we
need to sit down in the new year
and see how the technology works and so
i'm going to be very much dependent on
tom and my colleague peter hudson on
that one but that's the
aspiration okay thanks dave
everybody okay with that
furry yeah as i said it was just the
process by which the pids are actually
made it's not not the detail of each
each pig individually but the process
for all the pits
is the really the scoring and the
waiting i was more interested
yeah the process fact are you arrive at
the
at the pit final bid yeah
yeah how a pit has a pro approved yeah
yeah
okay what's that scoring and what's
what's the criteria we
are we looking at the return on capital
are we just looking at purely uh a
social effect
effect what are the what are the levels
and what is the scoring and what is the
waiting on each of those
so you you're not saying that you want
to go through each individual pid
no no completely the opposite is how the
pids are actually based
so there has to be a common criteria for
each pid
yes each each pig must be based against
the other so
what what what are the criteria for
which which we judge a pig by
okay if i can respond onto that so there
has
um historically been a process obviously
there's a paid
document which sets out and looks at
specific criteria things like
contribution to the strategic plan uh
rates
return health and safety and all of
those kinds of things
um and ordinarily as as the chair
pointed out earlier
in years gone by that was gone through
in detail
and those scores presented
and ordinarily you'd then expect
certain projects not to make the capital
program because they didn't score
heavily
however uh every time we've gone through
that
process every single capital project
has been added to the program regardless
of whether
it's met all of that criteria um so it
so whilst we have a documentation
process
that's followed um strict scoring
uh mechanism hasn't been um done so
in in the way that uh mr harper's
referred to
so it might be something that members of
the committee
want to revisit and have a look at in a
bit of detail
and put something forward and together
for future reviews of the capital
program because
ultimately we have um a shortage of
capital resources
so there there should be some basis for
making decisions as to what projects
come into the capital program
and what ones are either discarded or
put back
for future consideration but
as i said there's always been a process
followed
but when it comes to the the decision as
to whether or not
to include them all projects got
included
um when they were considered by members
at full council
right in i think that answers the
question thanks very much steve
yeah okay i think it's more more
we look at the pids and look at the cap
with the capital program
and say what can't we do
or where where do you in you know where
do we find the money
but we will go through that anyway so
anybody else got any questions
everybody happy always yeah always
okay then what time is it
oh where's the mince pies
hurry where's the mince pies
well i don't know i bet mine
where's the cream yeah i look and
chippy's eating one
[Laughter]
uh well next time i tell you what
what i'll do i'll i'll the first meeting
that we can have face-to-face
with this committee i will bring
the mince pies and stephen dengate will
bring the cream
yeah yeah that's the first meeting we
could
that we can have where we can sit there
in the town hall
sounds like a good plan yeah okay you've
just broadcast that live
on youtube so i'm not sure how many
people will turn up at the
top um
carry on with that
thank you very much well everybody who
is watching this
now have a very merry christmas and just
behave
um don't leave your house or or go to
any pub or anything just be able travel
stone bird
okay anyway where's tom
i'm i'm here would you like